hi everyone i'm swiss force wizards
depending on how Americanized you want
to pronounce my name today i'm gonna
talk to you about a pattern not a
library it's a pattern I'm calling the
wormhole state management pattern that I
kind of developed when I was working on
a library that some people are using and
I discovered this really cool pattern
that lets you manage state in a more
manageable way without using any any
dependencies without state management
libraries just using stuff that's
already in react so oh by the way I
don't have an intro slide because I
don't like those if you want to know
more about me or if you want to reach
out I think if you types wizards into
Google you're gonna find a lot of stuff
about me so I don't know how long you've
all been react developers but you might
remember back when react first came on
the scene it made a huge splash with
this unidirectional state management
system or do you need directional
dataflow because back then this was what
2014-2015 I don't know when I'm
presenting that's fun cool so I can't
open the chatroom
so back in 2015-2016 somewhere
thereabouts the way we used to build
these web apps was that you had a lot of
painful pain with doing state management
you could either use an event based
system like backbone which very quickly
grew to a point where you just had no
idea what's going on you click the
button and a bunch of events fired and
you really couldn't tell what was gonna
happen when you did anything on the page
or there was still a lot of jQuery stuff
things like that where every state
update caused a bunch of rear Enders and
a bunch of Tom grief rows and it was
just terrible so then oh and the other
popular one was angular with
bi-directional data flows where he had
bi-directional binding and you could
change the state of some variable and it
would magically update everything that
depended on that variable which sounds
really cool when you're building small
demos but then it very quickly becomes
very painful and grows gets out of hand
and you just actually it basically
becomes pretty problematic very quickly
that I don't know if you've worked with
code bases like that but it doesn't feel
nice when you change something and you
don't know exactly what's going to
happen or you have to trace too much of
the code to figure out how things are
actually working so the you direct
unidirectional data flow was this
wonderful idea from the Facebook team
from Facebook's react team where you
could suddenly understand how your
entire application work data would
always go just in one direction from the
top from your top component all the way
down through your component tree to the
bottom where something changed so you
always knew exactly what was happening
the idea was that your your UI would be
a direct representation of state you
would always know okay this is if I
change state I know that everything
updates and I don't have weird
additional things on top of my head
updates
actually D sorry the state from
notification is really bugging me so I
have to click that maybe I can see the
chat while I'm doing no just shows okay
so okay so now I can see the chat I
don't know if you can see the chat while
I'm sharing the screen but whatever so
basically the idea of the unidirectional
data flow was that it makes your
application more understandable your
data is going only in one direction
you always know what's happening you are
is a pure representation of state
because you have all of your states
stored in a single source of truth it's
very easy to sync between different
components so you can know what's going
on you can say okay I'm rendering
something all the way here on the left
and it depends on something a component
over here on the right path and you
connect them together over the single
source of truth and everything is
updating in super-awesome so that was
nice what I think we kind of you know
started taking it way too far
we everybody who was teaching reacted
back then and I think it still happens a
lot was saying
you should put everything in a in your
top component top component should hold
your states and it should hold the state
for your entire application and then you
had to deal with prop drilling you had
to pass everything down then you have to
pass callbacks back up this up the state
tree so the proper ruling was a huge
problem you ended up with extremely
tight coupling between components so if
you wanted to move a component from the
bottom of your Dom tree or of your
reactor 3 to a different part you
suddenly have to change every component
that was on that path so everything that
was between the component you were
actually changing and the component that
was so everything that was between the
component that held State and the
component you were actually changing you
had to change all of that if you wanted
to move your component somewhere else so
that was a huge pain in the ass
so people very smart people were like
you know what we can save we can solved
with state libraries so then we had this
proliferation of state libraries we had
Redux we have no backs I think we had a
couple of others Redux and MOBAs
climbing Redux and mob X I think are
still the main ones that people use and
they're great they're awesome libraries
amazing to use when when you're starting
out well maybe they're not amazing to
use when you're first starting out
because it makes your application really
complicated makes it very hard to know
it makes it relatively easy to know
what's going on but the complexity of
your application basically just explodes
suddenly you need to change five files
if you want to change how something
works you need to add reducers you need
to add actions then people are saying
you should have all of your actions in
one file but then your files become too
big and you start changing things into
sagas or chunks or whatever other things
there are but basically your codebase
becomes really difficult to understand
whenever you change something you
suddenly don't know everything it's
connected to which is fine in a way
because potentially if the abstractions
are well done you don't want to know
everything that's connected to your
component right or
to your state you also get this really
nice separation where you have a state
layer that handle that lives outside of
your component tree so that so it
becomes easy to change to move
components around you just hook them up
to your redox state or to your ma back
state and it kind of just works right
it's a pain in the ass to set up you
have to deal with a lot of boilerplate
code to get everything working and set
up and running when a new junior joins
your team they probably really struggle
with how to make anything work here but
there's just a lot to understand you
have a lot of complexity and what I
think is the biggest problem of these
libraries is that they break the
colocation principle so suddenly what
you're doing and what you're displaying
or your UI and your business logic user
interactions and all of that are just
not close together anymore you have to
keep a lot of context in mind to be able
to make any change you have to I don't
know how often you've approached a redux
or mobile code base that somebody else
build you weren't the one building it
but if you don't understand the entire
system it becomes almost impossible to
understand how anything works I remember
walking into a saga based into a saga
based project once and it took me three
or four days just to barely understand
how it works because you could click
something and a bunch of things happened
and then a bunch of other things changed
and I had a band I had a lot of unknown
side effects where things were really
rendering and changing that I didn't
even know existed or I wanted to just
change how a button works and I changed
that I made the made that small change
in the button and suddenly my headers
started changing and I was like what no
I didn't i don't want my header to
change in all in all cases maybe I just
want to change it in some cases so all
of that becomes really difficult and
means that you have to be able to
basically hold your your entire code
base in your mind which is great as long
as it's a small codebase if you use n
this principle of splitting up your mana
it's great because you can have small
simple apps each deployed in a separate
gem stack or wherever you deploy them so
that kind of helps with that complexity
but eventually your complexity is going
to grow I know we tried to work with
micro front-ends and that never really
went anywhere and was a huge failure so
what I want to propose today is a new
way of managing your state that mostly
solves all of these problems and makes
your life a lot better and I'm calling
it the world wormhole state management
because it's based on the idea that you
have a lot of local state combo
localized to the smallest possible part
of your state tree and then you have one
calls to make different parts of your
state communicate with each other so the
principle is that when you have state
that belongs just to a single component
where just a single component cares
about that you can just use local State
with react hooks now it's super easy to
use local State without too much trouble
you don't have to deal with the set
state well you still have a set state
function but it you don't have to build
a class-based component just to have
state you can use functional components
which are in my opinion - or to work
with and you can use look state locally
and it's self-contained within the
component anyone who looks at that
component can always know everything the
death component does all of the business
logic it's using you can then if you
have different components that work
tightly together that are really
actually tightly coupled like we'll
we'll do some examples later but let's
say you have a button and a display
component next to it that shows how many
times that button has been clicked you
can just share state between those two
components you don't have to go all the
way around to your global state just to
change something that it's that's right
next to you imagine imagine if every
time you wanted to ask your coworker
to help you out with something you would
have to write a form a formal request
for help then you would have to pass it
on to your manager then your manager
would pass it on to his manager then his
manager would pass it on to her manager
and then the CEO would look at that for
request for help and she would be like
yes it does sound likes wizards needs
needs auntie's help okay this is good
and then she would put that into HR and
then HR would look at it eventually and
maybe five days later it would come back
to Andy who's sitting right next to you
and she would say yeah totally you can
just click that button over there or
just copy/paste that thing and it's
gonna be fine so that's that's kind of
how we work with redux and mailboxes if
you go all the way around to do the
simplest possible things so with the
more with the one call pattern you get
the colocation of logic so anyone who
looks at the component can always
understand that component you minimize
you as a as the result you also minimize
the amount of code that needs to be
understood because you'll see with some
react hooks you can then make it very
easy to share state between components
without introducing a lot of extra code
you're not using any libraries which is
great for performance because it means
you're not downloading extra libraries
you're not compiling extra libraries
you're just using every stuff that comes
with react already and at least in my
experience this scale this same approach
scales pretty well from very small apps
that you're building is a tiny example
to huge apps that need that have a lot
of different layers or a lot of
different segments of the app that needs
to work together so rather than talk to
you and talk your ear off about the
theory I figured I would just show you
how this works if we go to this code
sandbox over here so you should still
see my screen and I wanna I'm gonna show
you how the wormhole state management
pattern evolves from the smallest
example to something that is more like a
bigger app using code and a bit of life
coding I haven't prepared a whole lot in
advance because you don't need a whole
lot in the bank that's kind of the point
of this pattern is that it's simple and
easy to understand you will however need
to be relatively familiar with hooks
because if you're not then it doesn't
work
so let's say we have
we have this code sandbox over here and
we want to make this plus one button
that is a simple counter I know that
this is a contrived example that's kind
of the point is that we don't have to
worry too much about the actual logic
behind it I can let me show you how I
use this in a more serious application
but the basic idea is that if you have a
counter component it doesn't really need
a whole lot you can say that you have a
count count and a cell count function
you take those from state you can use a
starting prop to set the starting value
then you create a plus 1 function which
calls set count gets a current count and
returns count plus 1 so very simple
function pretty simple logic we when we
click the button we're going to call
plus 1 and let's also display the
current count like this so I'm going to
add a breakpoint here but that so now
when I click on this you see the count
goes down I have am using completely
local state all of my logic is contained
in the component and it's still a
functional component and just set saying
ok count is now a state whenever I call
the set count function it get it takes
as its first argument a it takes it
takes a function as an argument so that
we can make it more dynamic week the
current count from state and updates the
state which then triggers only render of
the counter component so we now have a
counter component that works completely
independently we can make multiple of
them and it's still going to work might
need to add to make let's turn this into
a div so they don't overlap so we now
have to counter components that have
separate pieces of state and you can
render this anywhere and it's completely
independent and it always know what's
happening let's say this one needs to
start from five loads OC Code sandbox is
nice enough to actually maintain state
between reloads so that works nice as
well so you see that hot reloading works
with this approach and all of that stuff
now let's say that the each count
component needs to have a separate
display component and that display
component could be further down into
three but they're two they're basically
two components that work together so
we're gonna say it's a display and it's
gonna get count as a normal prop but
then say constantly display is component
attached some count and it returns a
function that's going to render
paragraph which is going to show that
count now no longer need the breakpoint
now I know this still looks this still
looks kind of lame and like a stupid
example but imagine if this were three
components deep or if it was like this
could be I don't know
a widget on your page somewhere that has
something where five to five components
need to work closely together we can
also say that okay you know what might
these default buttons are kind of lame
let's make a red button component that
looks better so we create a red button
component and this one is going to get
the set count callback and we return a
button that has that's we set plus one
so let's put in plus one and it's on
click and let's give it a background
thread so that you can see it's a red
button so we now have a heart to
actually pass it in nice when when edit
suddenly starts reminding us that we
forgot stuff so we have we still have a
pretty simple approach where we have a
button that does counting and we have a
display and we are doing this is
basically the old prop drilling approach
where we have localized state that is
shared between two components that work
very closely together this is great for
when you need to build widgets that are
relatively self-contained or widgets
that are I'm having trouble coming
with a fun example but basically imagine
if you had a header that needs to share
some state between just a couple of
components in the header itself you
could do that with this approach now
what if we want to connect both counters
together so that they are counting with
the same the same global state so now we
have component that live far apart in
the state tree and they need to work
together to manage global State we could
go with Redux and do a bunch of stuff
but instead what I prepared was a
wormhole context provider so we're now
going to create a wormhole that's going
to share state between two components
that are very far apart and these two
components will have an indirect way of
communicating without us we're going to
kind of were kind of hoisting state but
not too much they do here okay so we're
going to import the one whole context
provider from doesn't it autocomplete
from provider and the wormhole context
provider is a react component that does
a few things with its own local state to
make the state shareable and I'll show
you how that works so we take these two
and we render them inside the wormhole
context provider that so they're now
both children of the same global
provider this is similar to your redux
provider your mo backs provider except
we're going to do a few tricks to make
them easier to use let's see so we have
the wormhole context provider now we can
go into our counter and instead of using
state like this we're going to say we're
going to take state from our context and
we're going to take a little function I
called set shared count so set your
account and we say use context
and it's going to be one whole context
which we also need to support so import
one whole context from here and I'll
explain in a little bit how this works
so now we have display account which is
going to display state dot shared
account this is where if you're using
what's it called if you're using
typescript this makes it easier because
it gives you autocomplete on all of
these states and stuff I didn't want to
deal with that because I I just felt
like it was too much for this example
and now instead of set count we're going
to set share count and we're going to
just set it to state on shared state did
I actually call it plus one no it's not
ok we take the new state dot share count
plus one and now in theory this should
just magically work as long as we import
use context from react let's see so you
see now I'm clicking one button and
enter both updating yay
super awesome right and we'll go one
step further and make this even easier
to use so we now have two buttons that
are connected via a contacts provider so
the con the reacted context kind of
works is a wormhole in the background to
connect to components that are in theory
very far apart how the contact is does
that is that we are creating a context
called wormhole context this will in
practice you would probably have named
this differently for different sections
of your application
I forget what those would be called in
redux because it's been around two years
since I seriously used redux last but
the idea is that you create this context
you put in some state and you put in
your actions or your functions that you
use to manipulate that's it we're gonna
make that even better in a little bit so
then then you create a wormhole context
provider
functional component and which has a
state using just local state which is a
state or with a single variable but the
variable is an object so we are able to
have both shared count and you can add
let's say random string
random and I'll show you how that works
later or actually not gonna show now so
if we now have random string and we want
to display that over here we can say
state dot random string and it should
show up right next to us let's see I
need to load yeah so we need not have a
random string so basically we're using a
single piece of state but that state can
contain an object which then has a
richer more complex piece of state that
you did you actually use for your
application so we have that one called
context we then we have our initial
state we have our state state and we
have the context value which is another
piece of you state from react that holds
our application state and help any
helper methods that we need so right now
we just have set shared count you could
then add more actions here or I'll show
you in a bit you can use reducer to
clean up this part as well then to avoid
having multiple rear Enders whenever so
to avoid having multiple rear Enders we
then use a use effect to ensure that our
component only rear Enders when we when
our internal state changes so not when
the context value changes but when the
state's stored inside the context value
in the object changes then we render in
one whole context provider with our
context value and all of its children
which gives us the nested the nested
stuff below so what's happening now is
that when I when we call set shared
count that that goes into react context
via D by the provider goes into context
value
now let me change how I'm explaining
that so when we now render something we
take the wormhole context out of our
react context and we take its state and
a setter or an a helper method when we
call that helper method it's actually
being passed in from our context
provider which then calls this function
that we defined here that function calls
sets eight and updates the state which
then triggers a rerender via this effect
of our entire application of everything
that depends on that stage now this
isn't this potentially isn't as
performant as something like mo bags
because it doesn't keep track of what's
actually listening to which parts of
state but in practice it usually works
well enough if you're using Redux this I
think they say actually I haven't
benchmarked it but this should be about
as performance in swedux so we have that
now what we can do to make this even
easier to use
here you see we had all of this stuff
right so we have a have a context and we
have something that lets us manipulate
that context and it's kind of nice it's
nice that we have it in the counter
component but we can actually make it
even better let's change let's turn this
into a custom component so we're going
to say Const use shared counter you've
shared count which is going to be a
let's just call it a function function
use share count which doesn't really
take anything and it takes it takes
stuff out of context creates a +1
function and it's going to return our
current state of shared count and D plus
1 function actually easier to do it this
way to count and +1 function so we now
have a custom hook is this complaining
of it's fine so we have a custom cook
hook called
use shared count which talks to our
react context creates the wormhole
creates if and easier to use function
that just does +1 and export and returns
both of those as the count and s plus 1
so now when we go into the counter here
we can say cost plus 1 equals nil shared
count that will just work and then
display can be let us turn that into a
display count component so you can
display count which no longer needs to
take any props instead what it can do is
say count concert count equals use count
so there should now just work magically
so let's see if it dot yep so we now
created a hook that we can use in any
component no matter where it is in our
component tree that independently
connects to our global state or whatever
shared state we have and uses that state
to work just locally in the same
component so now if you're if you
imagine how this works from a what did I
do here so now if you imagine how this
works from the perspective of a jr.
that's joining your team or even you who
hasn't been working on a part of the
code base for six months or whatever or
you've just forgotten what you're doing
or how it works you can come to the
counter component and you say oh ok it's
using the shared count which is probably
some context and we're just taking out
the plus one the plus one function and
we call it in the red button on click
cool we can even completely remove this
and call this the plus button so we
change this to the plus button we then
move this over here so we're using the
shared count hook directly we call plus
one and you see it's still gonna work so
what what you just saw is how easy it is
to refactor your components it's easy to
move using shared State to a
different two completely different
components all of this component our
components are relatively independent
there are no longer tightly coupled they
can always get their own state from the
ship from the wormhole and they can
always use that state to do whatever
they need with it
which is really nice because you can
then it makes it easier to move things
around makes it easier to refactor it
makes it easier to say okay this is the
plus the plus button just takes plus one
from user account and the stuff with
that and we didn't have to use any
libraries to achieve this we just used a
bunch of default three I can feel it
okay we used a bunch of default react
machinery and it all kind of just works
too you can make this even simpler if
you go to go here and instead of your
state you can then use reducer I'm not
going to show you how to do that because
I think it would take a little too long
so there is flexibility and then here
instead of a reducer you would then just
pass any dispatch function on your video
and you'd then get really calm and then
you get basically the same complexity
not the same complexity but you get the
same power that you have with redux
where you can call this patch on your
reducer which then triggers the same
stuff here the same stuff for your for
the rear Enders and all of that kind of
a kind of trailed off there I'm sorry
but the idea is that if you like
reducers or if you have complex state
that needs to work together you can use
reducer and you still get all of the
same ease of use you get the same
flexibility you get the same location of
your logic and your while you were
actually using that logic and you can
still you can still have all of the
power that you need one other thing that
I wanted to mention was that with this
pattern I know that in redux and mo
backs and a couple of those others it
becomes very complicated what to do when
you have asynchronous actions with with
this approach it doesn't have to be
complicated because this can be an async
function so you now have an async
function that just works and calls set
state whenever it's ready and react with
the update and rerender your stuff and
it's gonna be fine you don't need to you
don't need any special knowledge of how
things work it's still just functions
it's just functions working together
with functions and you can insert
asynchronous stuff wherever you want so
that was that was what I had to show you
today I know it's kind of a pretty
simple example and I couldn't drive a
counter as much as I could to make it to
make it understandable where I'm going
at with the wormhole state management
pattern but still understandable so
we're not getting into the weeds of
application logic so yeah I hope you
enjoyed the talk and I hope that this
gives you useful ideas for how to
approach stuff I know I'm pretty sure
you can use this with redux or in any
existing react application you can just
start using it and it's going to be fine
I know it's not a library it's just a
pattern which I prefer because it
reduces dependencies and helps you it's
more about how to think about state
management versus use this library and
it's going to do everything for you
which I prefer and yeah so if there's
any questions I'm around otherwise you
can hit me up on Twitter later and yeah
that's it